[Applaudissements]
vous êtes aujourd'hui invité au Palais
de
l'Élysée parce que on m'a dit que vous
étiez
SAG que vous
étiez de bons petits enfants et de bons
petits élèves
oui oui est-ce tout à fait sûr
oui il y en a aucun de diable non et
bien c'est
dommage j'espère que le spectacle vous a
bien amusé
oui que vous en garderez un bon souvenir
oui et maintenant on va vous distribuer
quelques jouets et puis un goûter et il
faudra que vous vous rappeliez plus tard
que vous avez été un jour à l'Élysée que
vous y êtes bien amusé et que on n est
pas plus sévère
[Musique]
qu'ailleurs
je vous
souhaite pour vos parents pour vos
maîtres pour vous tous un bon Noël de
bonnes vacances et une bonne année et ma
femme et moi on vous
[Applaudissements]
embrasse